good afternoon CS one how are you guys
doing
today okay fantastic I'm glad to hear it
uh uh we have ourselves an exciting
class we're going to be talking about
deep learning there is no word of the
day um and that kind of reflects the
point that we're at a very interesting
part of the class where we have covered
a lot of the core material we're going
to be talking about uh fairness and
ethics on Friday uh and that is
something that you'll need for your
problem sets uh but the positioning that
I encourage for you for today is a
little bit more of a positioning of
Wonder than like a positioning of I must
memorize every single detail here
because this is a story that's unfolding
in real time uh and it's also one that I
think taking a step back and getting the
big picture is what's really critical
here now having said that we have an
exciting class where we are going to go
into the details of what is the mystery
behind deep learning we've heard so much
about it and today in class uh you get
to learn how that
works now deep learning is a tool but
the effects of the tool you've probably
heard about and you've started to see uh
in your life and in uh news around you
so a bunch of results recently have been
pretty impressive uh as you might have
heard computers were getting better and
better at board games but there's this
one board game that computers can never
play because it was thought to be so
complicated you needed human creativity
and in order to play it and it's this
game of go and go is complicated because
you know it has a board that's 17x 17
every every Square can have a white dot
a black dot or no dots and this just
becomes so exponentially large that
traditional compute power isn't so
helpful for being able to solve it uh
but then a team called um or a team in
the United Kingdom came up with an
algorithm that was able to beat the
world champion at this game and this was
perhaps the last standing board game uh
computers had got really good at making
art it started out a little bit uh
modestly computers doing these things
called Deep dreaming uh it then
transformed into computers could
recreate the styles of specific artw
workk like this picture might look like
it's by rembrand but it's not actually
it's been created by a computer uh and
if you guys have been paying attention
recently realize that you can now open a
thing called stable diffusion and you
can say write a text and the computer
will generate artwork based off the text
that you've used uh very controversial
uh but certainly also very
powerful uh and there are other
narratives that are perhaps more
inspiring like for example algorithms
that can look at this photo of someone's
skin and at the end decide that this is
in fact something that looks cancerous
so if you're far from a hospital if you
took a photo of this skin you put it
through the algorithm it says this is
cancerous maybe you know I need to go to
hospital right now uh and that seems
like quite an inspiring ing use and the
crazy thing about all of these examples
is that they're using the exact same
technology which is what we're going to
be learning today uh and just as a
little bit of a
warm-up I wanted to start today by
training a little critter everybody this
is going to be our little critter for
class uh the Little Critter is trying to
learn how to eat red dots and not to eat
uh green dots and this L Critter is
going to have a small little deep
learning algorithm at first Our Little
Critter is going to act pretty randomly
but I'm just going to let this guy train
throughout class and by the end of class
we'll be able to talk a little bit more
about how this little critter is working
and gaining
intelligence so this is going to be
exciting certainly this is a journey we
should go on and in order to go on this
journey let's make sure we bring
everyone along which means starting with
a little bit of
review in CS 109 we've been learning
about machine learning particularly
we've been learning about classification
tasks classification tasks are ones
where you're given a training data set
and based on that training data set
you're going to build a machine that can
take inputs and learn to predict outputs
and the outputs are always labels uh in
our problem sets that are either zero or
one and the fact that the outputs are
discret is what makes something a
classification
task the idea is you're going to use
that training data set and you're going
to build a little black box that little
black box is going to be governed by
these special numbers that we call
parameters and the metaphor we've been
using in cs19 for parameters are sliders
so once you build this little black box
you should be able to put in a new set
of inputs
so maybe different regions of someone's
Hearts you know like you'll give me all
of these inputs and the Machinery will
then be able to predict an output that
output we call uh Y and sometimes we
think of the probability of it as y
hat an important thing is if you ever
want to deploy one of these models you
want to be able to make sure that it
works beforehand so one thing that's
worth noting and is relevant to your
homework is instead of just thinking
about all your data set as one piece we
often take your data set and split it
and we'll take some set of our data set
and call it training that's where you'll
learn your parameters and then once
you've built your blackbox based off the
parameters learned from this part of the
data set we reserve some of your data
set for making sure that the algorithm's
working so we'll have a little test data
set we'll evaluate how well the
algorithm works and if it seems to be
doing well enough and it seems to be
acting fairly then we might consider
deploying it
okay questions feel free to just jump in
I have enough mandarins for uh a whole
bunch of questions
today now there's a whole bunch of ways
you could approach this problem we
learned about naive Bays first but then
on Monday's class we learned about
logistic regression that's really where
we're going to be picking off today
logistic regression is one version of
that blackbox algorithm and if you were
to look behind the scenes for the
blastbox algorithm it would look
something like this you take your inputs
every input gets weighted we sum up
those weighted inputs we then have to
squash the sum we interpret the squash
as a probability that the output takes
on the value one and then based on that
probability we make our classification
prediction this is really what it looks
this is the mental model you should have
but mathematically it's doing this you
know this is the weighted sum this is
the squashing function the sigmoid
function not to be confused with the
sigmoid from aian uh and then at the end
of the day gives you the probability
that y equals 1 it's not a true model of
the
world like nothing about the world works
like this it is a model that is useful
because it ends up making good
predictions in general but this whole
Machinery is a little bit
imagined uh and so even though it's
wrong and it's not capturing the way the
world really works it ends up with a
very useful
machine okay and that is our review now
it's time to take a journey from the
mathematics that we have for logistic
regression and get all the way to how
could we use this for skin cancer
detection I really like this idea by the
way of thinking about logistic
regression as being a Harry Potter
Sorting Hat you know you're going to
take some input uh and then you're going
to make your prediction it's like the
Harry Potter Sorting Hat looks at the
input and says Ah this is a one or ah
this is a zero and the beautiful thing
about CS 109 is uh while you might have
read the Harry Potter books and figured
that the Harry Potter starting hat was
interesting CS 109 you can learn how it
actually could work uh so how Harry
Potter's Sorting Hat could work is just
logistic regression perhaps but you
imagine that might not be powerful
enough um okay just to be clear inputs
in the case of your problem set
sometimes it'll be things like movies
that a person liked uh and so the inputs
you know each input index would
correspond to a particular movie when
you have a particular user they'll
either like or dislike those movies uh
then you wait them sum them and it will
end up producing your
prediction the intelligence comes from
the weights good weights and you make
good predictions uh random weights and
you don't make good
predictions so that was a theory and
that theory though led us to this
wonderful set of mathematics and this
wonderful set of mathematics says okay
where are we going to get smart weights
from we need smart weights where do they
come from well first let's write down
the logistic regression model based off
that logistic regression model we can
say for any one data point based on the
current values of thetas How likely is
that data point and this looked really
complicated but recall this was just the
log
likelihood of a bruli and because
basically we interpreted the output this
thing as the P parameter of a bruli this
is just a bruli where instead of the P
parameter you put in the output of your
logistic
regression this log likelihood it's a
scoring function it says hey how good
are your current parameters great
parameters will get a really high value
on this score awful parameters get a
very low value on the score a scoring
function is helpful but it doesn't tell
you how to get smart parameters in order
to do that you need a derivative so
derive your scoring function with
respect to every single parameter and
once you do that you can do hill
climbing now we have a particular
equation or um algorithm for hill
climbing that we use uh in C s19 which
is gradient Ascent uh and in gradient
Ascent you're going to have a system for
learning all your parameters we talked
about this on Monday but it you start
with random settings to parameters and
then over time you improve each
parameter based off of calculating its
gradient and then taking a very small
step in this direction of the gradient
for each of your J
parameters okay and the idea of this
gradient Ascent is if you know the
derivative of your scoring function with
respect to each parameter and if you
keep going uphill as you keep training
you'll get higher and higher scores and
higher and higher scores we think lead
to smarter and smarter
models okay before I move on to
artificial neurons let me just stop here
and give you guys a second to talk about
this with the person next to you
summarize what you've learned and see if
you can come up with a good question uh
take a minute and then we're going to
jump into deep learning because this is
our launching spot okay go for it have a
good little conversation with the person
next to you
e
good
so
as I said you know high level
perspective but this would be a great
time for for clarification questions if
you found something confusing certainly
other people in the class found it
confusing too so what's confusing about
this what's interesting what's
Curious yes can you just elaborate on
why
like different
why such a good question okay so at this
point class we have two totally
different algorithms for making
predictions for classification tasks we
have logistic regression and naive Bay
uh and let me tell you something very
interesting they're quite similar you
know they have a lot in common uh they
have the same level complexity have
similar number of parameters so for
similar problems they will both perform
pretty similarly the question was when
would you choose one or the other I'd
say if for example the ones you have in
your your problem sets it would be
acceptable to go with either so that's
my first answer is like for lots of
similar problems either one will be just
fine they're different but they're
similar in their effectiveness that's my
first answer it's kind of lame the
second answer is you could try both if
you had a problem you could run logistic
aggression you could run naive Bay and
see which one is doing better on the
testing data set and you say like that's
the one I want to go
with uh and then there is another
example which or answer which is all of
our examples in CS 109 have binary
inputs and binary outputs and if you
were to change that you say like your
inputs would become real valued or your
outputs become something like multiclass
uh it turns out inputs becoming real
valued logistic regression handles that
much more naturally and outputs being
multiclass it turns out naive Bas
handles that much more naturally so
three separate answers but maybe the
most satisfying is just try both of them
whichever one works best that's your
model I to clarify that I'm not sure if
this this but I think I understand how
there's different uses of it I'm
wondering like how the actual process I
know that for example the B point of uh
Na B was that we're going to like see
which probability is just bigger we're
going to choose that one yes regression
what exactly is different about like the
sigo yeah it's like the the sigmoid
doesn't even exist in naive Bas right
like KN Bas sees no sigmoid because it
it's not trying to directly model the
probability of Y given X
naive B is trying to you know use beian
calulations to get that now of course
that's almost impossible so we have to
make the naive assumption so there's
like it's like I'm going to approach
this just using pure basian thinking I
get to some point where it's impossible
I make a big assumption uh and that big
assumption leads to a classification
algorithm logistic regression has a
different path it says I'm not even
going to try and use Bay I'm not going
to try and use core ideas of probability
instead I'm going to build a probability
machine and this probability machine has
nothing to do with Bay nothing to do
with how probabilities actually work
it's just going to be like a little
machine that you stuff in x's and you
get probabilities out and it's going to
use this sigmoid mechanism so they're
pretty different paths uh but they lead
to they both lead to the same
functionality of I will make a
prediction yes I don't fly understand is
why we take log with respect to theta's
plural and not just Theta because when
we did the algorithm and the problems
that last week where we tried to find
the optimization we just took
one yeah good question so you didn't
mean logs you meant derivatives I
believe yes okay so the great question
was why do you have to derivative with
respect to every single Theta that's
actually if you want to do optimization
over parameters you need every partial
derivative of all the movable pieces
that's Hill criming needs all of those
partial derivatives it's not enough to
just say if I were to change Theta 0 how
would my score change I have to think
about every sing single Theta and if I
were to change them how would my score
change uh and that's the necessary
component for getting to hill climbing
AKA gradient Ascent so gradient Ascent
wants to know for every single parameter
if I were to change it how would the
score change so we need lots more
partial derivatives earlier in class
we'd only have single parameters we did
some assignments in when we looked at uh
maximum likelihood estimation where
you'd have a model with only one Theta
or only one parameter in that case you
only need one partial J
such a good question yes um if the data
is convex is there a functional
difference between gradient desent and
like setting all the partial derivatives
equal to zero uh okay good question if
it's convex would you get different
answers if you did gradient sent versus
if you uh set the derivative equal Zer
first of all I'd encourage you to try
setting this equal to zero and solving
for it it turns out to be very very very
difficult because of this sigmoid uh
having said that if you were able to
come up with an answer they would be the
same now there's a good reason we do
gradient Ascent cuz when we get to deep
learning setting taking a derivative
setting it to zero as a method of
optimization will not work we are going
to need this powerful tool of gradient
Ascent okay oh such good questions okay
one more um so for logistic
regression like we mentioned last class
um it gets its intelligence from Maximum
like estimation which is basically just
optimizing parameters that we use yes or
that um we need to at some point or
another pick a step size uh to perform
creting aent just wondering is there
some way of methodically picking a good
step size is there some sort of
convention for us to use the sort of
like strikes a good balance between
running time and atmosphere or is it
just purely an arbitrary Choice oh my
God I love I love it so there's this big
mystery over the step size and the step
size we use this little symbol for step
size and here we can have like super
small and really
large if you have really large step
sizes imagine you're trying to get to
the top of this hill and you have huge
step sizes you know there is this
problem that like if you're here and
your step size is huge and you go there
and if your next step size is huge you
could like end up bouncing back and
forth over the top of the mountain you
can never reach the top because your
step sizes are to Big imagine somebody
climbing Mountain instead of taking
small steps they're just leaping and
they just keep leaping over the top so
if you have really large uh step sizes
you kind of hit this problem that you
won't actually
converge just like this marker is not
converging so over here you have like
doesn't
converge so when you choose a step size
you might start with a large number and
then you might run it and it might just
never end up getting to a point where
gradient starts zero
um if you have a super tiny step size
you're going to avoid that problem
entirely like if you're trying to get to
the top of the mountain take a really
small step size you'll get there but as
you
said yeah if we had like run
time like this is going to be really
long and like as you get to smaller step
sizes you'll be able to converge quicker
we used to talk a lot about like the the
craft of deep learning and a lot of The
Craft of deep Lear where things like how
do you choose good step sizes you know
you could do something like start with a
pretty mediumsized one uh see if you're
in this uh territory um and if you are
then just make it a little bit smaller
now people have gotten more intelligent
there are things like adaptive gradients
where the computer is control of the
step size uh and it's choosing at each
step at each point what step size to do
that you'll learn about in further
courses so there's more sophisticated
techniques and and there's the lay of
the land good question and there's
another one that's what I was kind of
going to ask about like that there seems
to be parameters that are't just like in
within Theta like step size or like the
bias like like Theta zero like like are
those things all also like can you do
like a likelihood function on those okay
so the you bring up a good point so
there seems to be other parameters in
particularly the step sizes a good
example that theta0 actually is a
traditional parameter we think of it as
a parameter and we're going to have a
der and we're going to be doing our
likelihood on um you know it goes into
the likelihood function whereas step
size doesn't show up in the likelihood
function and so this sort of parameter
gets a special name it's not just a
parameter it's a hyper
parameter like it's super excitable um
and that's just to be like there's some
parameters that we're not going to try
and learn instead we're going to set
them ourselves uh step size being one of
them and as I said in cs19 we just give
you some step sizes they work pretty
well you can play around with them uh
and in further classes you can learn
really cool ways of making those
intelligent or making decision
Intelligent Decisions about those okay
yes actually if um your view C is zero
does that mean we're like disregarding
that
point yes it's not
important yeah exactly and your thetas
can then become positive or they can
become negative and if it's positive
saying like you know this one is going
to be shifting my probability positively
or you know to be more likely and if
it's negative saying this data Point's
making me think the probability is
smaller so there you go you can have
zero you can have positive you can
negative for
thetas okay and then you can put it
through hill climbing and you get to a
point
fantastic there's such a simple idea
behind deep learning it's amazing how
close you are the simple idea about deep
learning is hey you know that logistic
regression that we just spent a lot of
time talking about that logistic
regression
is like a cartoon model of how a human
neuron works now if you haven't studied
Neuroscience that's totally fine I'm not
going to give you a really detailed idea
of how a neuron works but I'm going to
give you a cartoon model so in a cartoon
model your brain is filled with these
things called neurons did you know that
and neurons have inputs often from other
neurons but they could be from things
like uh the retina which is getting
light input uh so it has all these
inputs that come into any neuron
cell and for those inputs some of those
inputs will be super important like if
this neuron gets an input from this
particular input it's definitely going
to fire so the neuron gets all these
inputs if the charge builds up high
enough the neuron then fires and then
any other neuron it's connected to will
then get its input so one of the ideas
somebody had is hey this logistic
regression looks a lot like a cartoon
model of what's going on in our
brains but imagine you tried to learn to
do a task and you only were given one
human neuron it seems unlikely that one
human neuron could become very smart uh
instead if you want to do a task you
might want to think about having a whole
brain and a brain you can think of it as
being a network of neurons where the
this neuron would then connect to other
neurons and this whole network of
neurons would then be able to Output
predictions so the simple idea is what
if we just took a bunch of these
logistic regressions think about every
single logistic regression as like one
tiny little Lego piece and we can start
stacking these Lego pieces on top of
each
other and that's a simple idea so what
you learned on Monday was that core unit
and once you start putting those units
together you get what we call a neural
network a AKA deep learning the term
deep comes from that you have depth in
your layers of logistic regressions
and that's the core idea behind the
revolution AI we could just walk out and
be like now you know deep learning but
of course that's unsatisfying can I give
you guys a little bit more
details um okay anyways this is the idea
that leads to alphao self-driving Cars
computer making art and at its core deep
learning is just many logistic
regressions pieced on top of each
other can I give you guys an example to
show you this a little bit in more
detail I'm going to use this running
example of computer vision
computer vision is the hard task of
looking at an image and deciding what's
in it so you guys are very smart humans
uh what's in this
image yeah it's a handdrawn zero but if
you had to predict a zero or one you
would say zero and how about this
image ah such smart humans we are we
have huge neural networks that are
helping us with this prediction actually
it is very misleading because you have
billions of neurons helping you make
that decision so your brain actually
starts with a very complicated
representation when you see this it's
hitting the back of your eyeball a thing
called the retina and the retina is you
know seeing amounts of light that hit
different parts another way of thinking
about this is a very similar analogy is
what the computer sees the computer
doesn't see a picture of a zero instead
it sees a whole bunch of pixels which
either could be black or white and that
whole bunch of pixels to it just looks
like a list or a grid of zeros and ones
same thing with your brain when you
first see this image it's a whole bunch
of light respon is on the back of an eye
it doesn't have meaning computer vision
is the particular type of neural network
that could take an image and then make a
prediction and you know just to be clear
the reason that you find this easy is
you have hundreds of millions of neurons
in fact visual neurons make up about 30%
of your brain so when we look at this
problem you're going to think of all
these tasks is quite easy but that's
because you have such an impressive
neural network and actually a fun thing
is the first layer of your neural
network actually happens in the back of
your head which is not that important
right
now imagine you had to do this task and
I just gave you a single logistic
regression unit it would be really
difficult the X's the features in this
case will correspond to each different
pixel in the image if you took a
particular image that would turn turn on
all the X vectors and then you could
have a logistic regression that could
wait each of those Summit squash it and
then make a prediction but this would be
a little bit similar to asking a single
neuron to learn how to see you have 30%
of your brain to see it seems
unreasonable that a single logistic
regression could possibly find good
thetas you're like can't we just use
gradient ascent and it'll just get
better and better and better and the
answer is no this model of logistic
regression is just too far it's too puny
to tackle such a large task there's not
enough parameters so even though you can
have a great optimization algorithm we
can write a likelihood function we can
try and optim it there's no set of
parameters that will start to do a good
task or a good job at this
task anything confusing about that
interesting curious yes so can you can
you kind of go over again like what
differentiates this from
like thing like being able to tell
you're like a movie or not like why is
this not doable you know one way so the
question is why is this not doable but
the movie thing was doable it's a good
question um part of it is that the task
is hard
part of it is think about the number of
inputs like how many pixels do you have
here and the number of inputs is really
really really really really large uh and
the combination of those inputs that
leads to your prediction is very
complicated so you have a huge dimension
for x and what makes for a y the true
methodology for deciding if this is a z
one is very complicated you know it's
not just is there a white here because
you know the white could be over here
when you draw your zero whereas for if
this was a particular movie it's much
easier because it doesn't change so much
like if somebody likes this movie then
it has a very consistent impact on
whether or not they like your target
movie so two answers one is much higher
Dimension the second is much more
complicated interaction between the
inputs to making the
output Compu
right yes it could be fixed with more
Compu power but the other part can't be
yes fantastic question yes do we
understand exactly why it becomes really
powerful to stack these up or did we
just kind of do it and realize
it yeah there's some people who would
say they have some guesses but you're
not completely wrong in that we did it
it seemed kind of like a cartoon model
brain and then it worked and then we
started analyzing it uh but now that
we've analyzed it there are some cool
theories that say like oh you could
learn nonlinear functions uh there's
actually no limit to the functions you
could learn uh and people are still
trying to tell more and more Nuance
stories for why this works but your
Insight was correct people basically
just tried this wait can I tell you a
hilarious thing somebody proposed this
and they tried it and it didn't work
because their computers were too puny
and then no one researched it for a
really long time and then a couple
people were like hey computers are
really good should we try that old idea
and then it worked and they got Turing
Awards really uh all of them uh but
anyway so yeah it turns out the
functionality was really what drove the
research I'm going to start drawing a
logistic regression like this if you
guys don't mind like this is a logistic
regression but now I'm going to kind of
ignore all the middle parts the
squashing or the summing and the
squashing I'm just going to have an
arrow that says all of these inputs get
summed and squashed and they lead to
this output does that sound
reasonable okay now you know logistic
regression maybe it could do a good job
sometimes but it's not always going to
do a good good job and so the very
simple humble idea that somebody
proposed and it didn't work cuz their
computers were too puny and then it was
a huge deal later is what if we had
stacks of neural networks and to be
clear here I'm going to say you have
your inputs and you have your outputs
but I'm going to introduce a new thing
called a hidden layer and every single
thing in this hidden layer is going to
be a logistic regression connected to
the inputs
and then once I have this hidden layer
I'll build a logistic regression that
takes the hidden layer as its input and
then predicts the
output I am going to just to give you an
idea of this as I said every single
Circle in this hidden layer is a
logistic regression it's going to take
every input weight it in its own way
with its own parameters sum it squash it
and then it will turn on or off so this
circle represents one logistic
regression but so does that Circle this
circle is also logistic regression it
has the same inputs but it's got its own
weights so it may turn on or off in a
different way every single one of these
circles is now a logistic regression so
you have a huge amount more parameters
and then finally if we did this we'd
have a whole bunch of zeros and ones and
that's not a prediction so we're going
to take all of the outputs of these
logistic regressions and call them
inputs to a final logistic regression
which is going to predict uh r0 or
one cool or what what a simple idea if
we can understand this that is you know
this now counts as deep learning because
we have depth of our neurons you can
imagine the depth is that at some point
you have a logistic regressions whose
inputs were the outputs of other
logistic
regressions
okay there are so many parameters here
you know if you imagine this final
logistic regression we've got a waiting
for every single output but how about
over here there's a whole bunch of
parameters in fact I'd encourage you to
think about how many parameters there
could be but for now I'm just going to
say we have way more parameters than we
used to
have
okay uh and just to be clear you know
what we just described to you is a
neural network many ltic uh regressions
stack to each other uh and deep learning
is the process of maximizing likelihood
for a neural
network uh and you know at this point
you can imagine as it's just like
logistic regression but now your input
to Output matching is just going to be
lots of logistic regressions
LOL okay it's a whole slide just for
that one awful joke can I show you a
demonstration I feel like it's cool to
talk about it and show it in slide but
like wouldn't be great to see a real
live neural network let me show you one
that does this task of predicting zeros
and ones oh hey our Critter is still
learning this whole time that we've been
talking it's been
practicing here is a logistic regression
or sorry a deep Learning Network because
it's not just one logistic regression at
the bottom here you're going to have
inputs and at the top you're going to
have predictions I'm going to handdraw a
zero uh here we go and I'm going to be
not great about
it and our Network's job is to take all
those pixel values and predict if this
was a zero or
one and if you look at it at the very
bottom of this neural
network we have a bunch of cells that
represent the initial pixel values of
what I drew does that make sense then
every single Cube here is going to be
its own logistic regression we'll look
into those in a little bit but if you go
to the very top at the very top we have
logistic regressions that represent that
have numbers above them this is a
logistic regression that's associated
with a zero 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and do you
notice that when I drew that zero the
logistic regression associated with a
zero is the one that turned on so
overall it's taking pixel values and
recognizing it's a zero if we drew
something different like a
seven you know it'll take pixel values
down here just what I drew and then turn
on this one cell that represents a seven
uh or if I drew let's say a one uh it
could take all these pixel values and
then turn on that one cell that
represents a
one that's the input and that's the
output but clearly it doesn't just have
one logistic regression anymore we have
a whole neural network so if you look at
this final cell up here it is a logistic
regression and its inputs are not coming
from the pixels its inputs are coming
from all of these other logistic
regressions which are turned on in
different ways uh and if you looked at
any one of them you can see that any one
of these is a logistic regression whose
inputs come from this previous layer we
call these things layers uh of logistic
regressions and if you looked at a
different one like this one turned on
but it had the same inputs as the other
one we looked at it's just probably
weighted those inputs differently so
every single Cube here is a logistic
regression uh and as you get lower and
lower um you know there logistic
regressions pulling from different parts
of the
image okay that's it that is deep
learning and at this point because you
understand logistic regression you could
just start stacking these things on top
of each other and you would have your
own neural
network now of course the difficulty
will always be where did you get those
thetas from you imagine if somebody made
this neural network and every parameter
was random it wouldn't be able to take
pixels and predict what's in the
picture all of its intelligence will
still be coming from the parameters so
the mystery still will be I can make a
neural network but how could I learn
those
parameters so is there any to where you
start your parameters or you truly just
pick random you truly pick Rand there's
one thing that's very different from
what you do in your problem sets or
logistic regression in logistic
regression we start all our parameters
at zero but for a neural network it
turns out to be important that you start
all of your parameters randomly and that
allows the different neurons to learn
different things um but no really we
start random there's no like smart
starting point it's just start it at
random and then Hill Climb of course
we'll get into the
details yeah okay question so
intuitively like what are these like
cubes in each layer every single Cube is
its own logistic
regression it takes inputs it weights
those inputs it squashes those inputs
and then it comes up with its own value
which is the squashing of all those
inputs weighted inputs so every single
Cube it is one logistic regression it
will have its own parameters and then
we'll do the summing squashing uh based
on those parameters is that answer yeah
also like what are the like combination
of those cubes then for each of these
like rectangles oh like over here like
these layers yeah like each layer we
have like a bunch of different like
rectangles right
combination those I mean I call these
things layers when you get deeper in
here we have these kind of grid light
ones that has it's a particular way of
doing uh images where we kind of have a
few neur logistic regressions that as
you notice have smaller number of inputs
like they just take four inputs that's a
nice little trick for images not worth
focusing on too much we'll talk about
that later um but these three layers are
you know they're not fully connected
it's not that every single cube is
taking every single input As an X as a
nice little design trick yeah so I know
you said that the intelligence comes
from like the uh weights but then also
like you have to decide beforehand like
how deep are you going to go and within
each layer how many
um going to be so how do you decide that
like is some intelligence in that too
it's a lot like this I would call those
hyper parameter so this is a little bit
more like the the art and craft of deep
learning is you construct how many
layers you construct how many neurons
per each layer uh maybe there's some
like neat little thing you'll do at the
beginning so that these neurons have
fewer inputs uh all those things are
artistic choices I would
say of course there was one person who
was like can I have the computer build a
neural network that could make those
choices for me and people have
definitely done that and yet still I
still see a lot of people just being
like we'll make a bunch neural network
it'll have like you know 40 layers uh
and each layer will have 100
neurons so artistic choices I'm just ask
a question so if it's artistic U so you
just have to like you know uh practice
your own way and see your accuracy go
have I yeah exactly so if you you could
do something like if you didn't know you
could make two neural networks train
both of them and then see which one
starts to get smarter and then that's
how you can make your artist IC
Choice sounds a little more like
optimization
then um
yeah okay so at this point I hope you're
understanding this big picture that deep
learning is a bunch of logistics pointed
together You' visualized it hopefully
you understand it but I haven't told you
where we're going to set all those
thetas I've now exploded our number of
thetas without talking about how we're
going to set them and that seems
impossible which leaves us with the fin
mystery for today how do we train and
you guys are getting that close to
understanding deep learning it is such a
simple idea Logistics on top of each
other but you need to be able to answer
this question as well and the start of
this journey is going to be maximum
likelihood estimation we're going to say
everything in our neural network is a
parameter and we want to choose the
parameters that maximize the likelihood
of some training data set there we go
okay first a couple learning goals
uh I do want you to walk away from
today's class understanding chain rule a
little bit better and understand how
chain rule is the heart and soul of the
gaining of intelligence for neural
network the Deep
learning I do want to De demystify deep
learning like you guys might have heard
about deep learning you might have heard
people talk about it like it's some sort
of sentient being but now I want you to
understand no it's it's something you
could uh tangibly understand uh and then
finally you know one of my goals is you
walk out today so ready to get the big
picture of the logistic aggression that
you have to do for your problem
set okay and now it is time for some
math worth learning we are going to go
through the math that is how deep
learning gets us intelligence and this
might become something you could expect
should become common knowledge like as
deep learning becomes more and more
pervasive it impacts Our Lives more and
more whether or not you build it or you
just want to understand this tool that
exists in society we should know this
this math okay A little bit of new
notation I am going to write it on the
board over here so that we can keep
track of it over
time I got X that was our inputs of our
little black box I've still got y hat
that's our output of our black box but
now I've got a hidden layer H uh and I
am going to talk about each of these
things as XIs that's nothing too new I'm
going to ref refer to each of these
neurons in the hidden layer as H I think
I call it J right yeah so we're going to
call each of these ones
HJ and HJ is going to have a whole bunch
of parameters associated with it and the
parameters associated with HJ I'm going
to be calling the
thetas and in superscript I'm going to
say it's for
HJ
and that's going to tell me that I'm
going to have a bunch more thetas oh
sorry this is thetas for the hidden
layer and particularly for this logistic
regression it's going to have a Theta
for every single one of the inputs so
this HJ will have a Theta for x0 X1 X2
X3 does that make sense so
HJ is going to have a Theta for Theta 0
it'll have a Theta for Theta 1 you'll
have a Theta for Theta 2 a Theta for
Theta you know for
X3 and so because of that we're going to
think of oh it looks like they're
hanging out together um we're going to
imagine there's going to be a whole set
of parameters for this hidden layer and
for this hidden layer it will have two
different subscripts it'll say I have a
parameter for in this hidden layer every
combination of some input and some
hidden
neuron wow that's a whole bunch of param
every single one of these hidden neurons
is a logistic regression so
HJ is going to be a logistic regression
you guys ready for it that means it's
going to be the squashing
function of the weighted sum of two
things one of those things is
X and the other thing is going to be
Theta uh is going to be the Theta H's
for J but you know this sum this or this
transpose is the same as saying okay
we're going to sum over all the inputs
in x i we're going to take every
XI and we're going to weight it it's
going to be a weight so it's a Theta
it's coming from this hidden layer so
it's going to have this superscript
H and particularly this is the one
that's going to the J hidden neuron so
it's going to have a j subscript there
and we're going to Loop over all the
inputs
uh and there's going to be a differenta
for every single input
here so this is my mathematical way of
saying every single Circle here in this
hidden layer is going to be a logistic
regression it's going to be a logistic
regression which has its own weights and
there'll be one weight for every input
hidden layer
combination if I gave you x's and I gave
you all the thetas you could use this
formula to decide if HJ was turned you
know close to one or not
when you actually evaluate this this
will become a
number okay that was complicated let's
take some questions yes so how manyas
would there be in I guess that example
it's such a good question I'm going to
ask you in just a second but I'm going
to let you guys start thinking about it
you know like imagine there's uh 20 or
you
know 40 things here and 10 things here
and one thing here you could start
asking yourself how many thetas are
there but I will ask you in just a
second so think about it for a
moment I do want to introduce just a
little bit more notation and the last
piece of notation I'd like to introduce
is that all of this just describes the
logistic regressions that go from X to H
there's one final logistic regression
that takes all of these outputs as
inputs and then predicts oi and in that
final logistic regression you know y hat
is the output of a logistic regression
so again there's a sum this sum is going
to go over and it's going to pull out
each of the
H's and it's going to weight them and
it'll be another
weight and to distinguish the weights in
this part of the neural network from the
weights in this part in the neural
network we're going to consider these
weights to be Theta with Y in the
superscript and that's just so that we
can tell apart these weights from these
weights so these are the weights in the
H layer and these are the weights in the
Y layer
okay and then you know here it is on the
screen for people who have trouble
reading on the board but I'm going to
keep this on the board the whole class
through yes does that every H value on
every single value and Isa value that
you choose what you said was 100%
correct that's awesome so every single H
gets the exact same set of inputs and
the only thing that's different is that
they will have different thetas
different
parameters okay rock and rolling what I
don't understand is you stud that the
little circle is the is this the
regression thing so how is it having
thetas if everything's contained within
the
circle this little circle it's going to
be a computation you'll start with the
x's and how do you compute the value of
this little circle the way you compute
the value of this little circle is you
use this formula so you take all your
x's and you're going to be waiting them
by these thetas These thetas are going
to live in the memory of your computer
uh and these thetas are going to tell
you how you should be waiting the X's
for this particular H so you weit each
of your X's get that number throw it
through our sigmoid function and that
will be HJ if you chose a different H it
would use the same X's but it would have
its own thetas again this would live
somewhere in your python memory um it
would pull out those thetas uh it would
do the sum the squash and it would get
its own
value okay
fantastic so let's do a forward path
if we take a picture of a one we don't
have to guess the values of X we're told
what they are each value of x
corresponds to a pixel value like this
will be the pixel value in the bottom
right corner and that will be the pixel
value in the top left
corner then once we have X's we could
calculate every single hidden neuron we
could save every single hidden neuron
calculate yourself based on the x's in
order to do that they're going to use
this formula which is also over here and
this formula is going to take those x's
and weight them every single thing in
the hidden layer has its own set of
Weights so they will come up with
different answers even though they're
all taking the same X's since each one's
weighting its own weights they'll get
different answers and then you'll
activate the hidden layer we call this
the forward pass this is the prediction
pass so we took an image uh we activate
the hidden layer and then finally we're
going to activate this layer this layer
is going to say okay I'm going to take
each of these as my inputs I'm going to
weight each of those inputs using the
weights that are in this part of my
Python program and then I'm going to get
that Su squash it and I'm going to call
that uh my
prediction okay so that's forward
pass if we wanted to get to the point of
learning these thetas it's now time to
score our forward pass so we did our
forward pass how good a job did we do
and the scoring function we want should
be derivable with respect to the
different thetas so when we say how good
a job do we do we don't want to just
give us 100% if we got it right or a 0%
if we got it wrong instead we'd like to
have something that we could learn from
so again the scoring function we'd like
to use at this point is going to be
maximum likelihood
estimation we're going to say
hey you're predicting something binary
and if you're predicting something
binary you could imagine that there's
some beri parameter p
you come up like this very final thing
is going to be interpreted as a
probability so we call this y hat is
like actually a
probability and we're interpreting this
very final thing as the probability that
the label should be one we say whether
or not the label should be one it's a
beri and what came out of your logistic
regression was the parameter for that
beri and we can say How
likely is a true label of one if your
probability was A8 so if your
probability is a08 you can say the
likelihood here is going to be 8 to the^
of 1 time2 to the^ of 0 so 8 if you
guess if the true label is a one and
your final probability is of 08 we can
score that and we score in the exact
same way that we score logistic
regression which I appreciate is
complicated right we've got this whole
like brli thing we have this continuous
likelihood function that over there is
the log of this continuous likelihood
function so this scoring function is not
very good for computers we want the log
version of it and we end up with this
crazy
equation but the highle picture is the
same you know you could make a
prediction end up with a probability and
I can score that probability using the
mle
mindset questions Curiosities
concerns yeah like what's actually in
layer age is it is it another set of
datas for each progressions or is it
actually a zero
both there will be thetas and those
thetas will lead to actual values they
won't be zero and one because they're
coming out of a sigmoid they'll be
something between zero and one uh but
they'll be smooshed so be close to zeros
or ones and so they're both true there
are thetas they'll have numbers there
will be activations like if you put an
input you can activate the hidden layer
itself so there's both a Theta you can
think of those as living between the
layers and then there's the layer itself
which will end up getting on taking on
values
yeah the probability sorry what was the
I couldn't hear you score the
probability ah we score the probability
using mle so we're going to say How
likely does one data point look like
based on this prediction the data point
will have a true label what's the true
label
here so you end up with a probability
out here let's say it's a08 how do you
score the 08 if the true label is one so
y hat is going to be your 08 uh and the
true label is going to be y
and so you could put that into this
little function here it's 8 put that
through a log times it by one because
the true label was
one uh this is going to be Times by zero
so we're going to forget that it'll just
be 1 * log of8 will be your score so you
have these two things this y hat which
is the probability that you just
calculated and if you had a true label
because this is training data then you
can put those two things together into a
score it looks really confusing I feel
like this equation is incredibly
confusing for what it really is it's
just taking a probability and scoring it
based on the true label uh and it's just
using this derivable version of the brui
probability Mass
function
insane but very clever good job whoever
figured this
out okay yeah this is a sand check so I
know you just said that layer H is
basically a list of like outputs of the
sing W but wouldn't we need to pass on
like a list of binary inputs when we do
the second round of logistic regression
ah what a good question do you remember
earlier somebody asked me hey when would
you use logistic regression when would
you use naive Bays I threw out a little
bit of an interesting comment I said hey
if your inputs weren't binary if your
inputs were something like real valued
that's totally fine for logistic
regression it doesn't care but totally
breaks naive base it turns out logistic
regression doesn't rely on the fact that
X's are zeros or ones
logistic regression is totally fine if
those are like 7 it's totally fine if
those are like you know 20 it doesn't
even change the probability analysis
because the mle is all just based off of
that final output anyways so there's no
probability analysis here it's just a
black box and that black box is totally
fine with real valued inputs good
question yes does that impact the answer
though that you would get if you're
putting in nonbinary things like I'm
thinking in terms of maybe our movie
example instead of doing they like it
and they don't like it
they 70% like it you know what logistic
regression would just learn different
weights okay and it would probably do
better if it had richer inputs such a
good question I love this yes right back
to the L like
yeah like if your true value is a number
from like 0 to 10 in this case let's say
Z or one we're still into the predicting
zeros or ones because if it wasn't a 01
then we couldn't use the beri probably
Mass function we'd have to use a
different one I'll talk to about that at
the end of today's class but actually
yeah we are just predicting handdrawn
zeros or handdrawn
ones okay
fantastic this is a crazy complicated
slide it gets a little bit easier from
here it looks scary at some point but
it's just a ruse so if you can
understand this you're in a good plot
place
okay ah okay we put it all together and
we start to write neural networks in
much more complic or compact ways we've
got our X we've got our H and we've got
our y between the X and the H we have
some thetas between the H and the Y
we've got some more thetas and then I
have this question that somebody asked
me earlier and I was so cheeky and I
said you figure it out no I'm just
joking so let's say our X is size 40 our
H is size
20 in this
case my first question for you is how
many parameters are there in this part
of the neural network why I'm after I
ask you that I will ask you how many
parameters are there in this part of the
network why don't you talk about with
the person next to you come up with a
guess there's no uh reason that you
should be able to answer this at this
point but if you can fantastic uh and if
not we'll talk about
it
okay let's do
this who thinks it's a
yeah who thinks this
B A bunch of folks who thinks it's C no
how about d a couple
folks okay fun fact they're actually all
a little bit
wrong no no they're very close I would
say if I had to choose between these I'd
probably choose B because this this
final layer is actually just one
logistic regression and it's inputs are
the hidden layers so if there's 20
elements in the hidden layers it'll have
20 inputs and each of those inputs need
to be weighted exactly once so you'll
need 20 parameters the reason I say it's
slightly wrong is because I think the
true answer should be 21 and the reason
is we're not going to get too much into
this in this lecture but you know he had
that bias term when we did logistic
regression we're still going to keep
using those in our neural networks so
there'll be one extra term for a bias
but that's not important right now you
know really the number of things in this
Y is not too
large how about this one how many
parameters are there in this chunk of
the neural network so this is the part
that connects the X's to the
H's think about it think about it it's
time to vote okay imagine there's a plus
one to all of these who wants to say
800 bunch of folks who wants to say
20 that would be nice who wants to say
820 that' be nice too who wants to say
16,000 just all the parameters are there
will
again uh in this case there's actually
you know a little bit more than 800 if
you forget the bias term there would be
exactly 800 because every single one of
these hidden neurons will have a
parameter for every single input so each
of these are going to have 40 parameters
and there's 20 of them so there's 20 *
40 parameters uh in this chunk there'll
be a few more once you have bias terms
and 40 * 20 is 800 oh my God my I got it
wrong it says how many parameters in
total ha 800 + 20 is 820 man reading
comprehension Chris tisk tisk okay so
there's something like 820 parameters if
you have 20 uh hidden neurons and 40
things in your
inputs all you need
in order to train is a partial
derivative of that likelihood
function for every single one of those
820 parameters so let's go do 820
partial derivers who's ready yeah
yeah let's try and do something Brave
let's talk about how we can get the
partial derivatives for all these 820
parameters that all need setting and we
only have to do three things we only
have to write the likelihood assumption
or you know get this likelihood equation
and then once we have that we just have
to derve it with respect to all of the
different components and why do you need
this cuz if you want a good neural
network you need good thetas if you want
good thetas you want to search for ones
that maximize
likelihood you can maximize likelihood
using optimation optimization techniques
such as gradient Ascent but for gradient
Ascent you need to have the partial
derivatives of the scoring function you
have with respect to every single
movable part in your model and all of
our movable parts are the thetas so that
is the story and it basically
says uh when you guys actually I just
want to have this met thing that
understanding mle applied to deep
learning is only hard because there's
these four compounded oh sorry steps to
get there so oh before we jump into this
I think this is funny you know like this
is a picture of a huge deep learning
model and we've got scooby. do saying
hey gang let's see what deep learning
really is because at the end of the
episodes they always reveal and in this
case oh my God it's just convex
optimization it's just a whole bunch of
derivatives happening that can make your
Theta smarter okay let's jump into
it this is exactly the same as logistic
regression our model is going to
eventually output a probability which
we're going to assume is the probability
that the class label is one the
probability class label is zero is going
to be one minus that that's our
assumption is that this model is
creating those probabilities BAS off
that we can get a super sweet scoring
function if you had a single data point
the way you could score this is you can
use your beri probability Mass function
so why hat is the probability that came
out of your neural network you know if
you want to get really detailed into it
it's coming from this equation but it is
the probability that we're assuming is
the probability that y equals 1 and
because of that that's the parameter of
your bruli your data point has a True
Value y it'll be the probability raised
to the 1 or Z which which is the true
value Y and this is the continuous
version so great why is a beri we can
use that as our likelihood function if
we have many data points in our training
example we're just going to do the
product of those many times so you get a
whole bunch of the outputs of my I the
output of my logistic reg or my deep
learning for the I training example
raised to its
label now this is going to be
numerically unstable so instead of
maximizing the likelihood we're going to
maximize the log likelihood gets the
same answer answer but it's going to be
much easier for our computer friends so
instead of doing this likelihood we're
going to take the log of it and we take
the log you get the exact same equation
from mle of logistic regression like
this is exactly character for character
the same if you have end data points it
has this inner sum for each of those
data points
amazing so this is the same as logistic
aggression this is the same as logistic
regression uh finally though all we have
to do is derive this with respect to
every single one of our thetas all the
thetas here all the thetas here so you
know we had 800 here and 20 there we're
going to do that
derivative
now our goal is the derivative with
respect to all of these output
parameters and the derivative with
respect to all these hidden parameters
if you can calculate all those partial
derivatives as a function you are
done here is a bad approach let's say
you want to calculate the derivative
you're like I've got this scoring
function and I want to get the
derivative with respect to say a Theta
here a bad approach was be you could say
oh y hat is actually this this is the
equation for how y Hat's calculated so I
can just substitute that into my
equation and so instead of having this
log likelihood here you know I could uh
put that into my equation then I could
keep chaining these as I go that's would
be correct but will lead to a math bug
instead what I'd like to show you guys
is derivatives without tear how can we
derivatives without tear cuz this is
going to be important because deep
networks often don't just have one layer
they have multiple layers so we need to
know how to do this calculus without
making us want to pull out our hairs so
no tears calculus and it comes down to
the chain Rule and Mr blanchon was uh my
high school math teacher and he taught
me the chain Rule and I told him I don't
think it was going to be useful and he
was right it was in fact useful and now
governs most of artificial intelligence
chain rule says if you have a function
you can decompose using some
intermediate step I find this a little
bit abstract but I find this really easy
to understand you want the Dera of log
likelihood with respect to a Theta
there's an intermediate result which is
the probability so get the derivative of
log likelihood with respect to that
probability and then you can multiply it
by the derivative of that probability
with respect to the thing that went
towards calculating the probability you
can decompose each step in your
calculation of log likelihood and get
the derivative piece by piece also don't
forget sigmoid we love it because it's
got this beautiful derivative and uh
another thing not to forget you know the
derivative of a sum is the sum of the
derivative so often from now on I'll
just be thinking about a log likelihood
that doesn't have the sum because you
can do the derivative of this log
likelihood without the sum then you can
just put a sum outside and it will be
the
same okay in Monday's class when we did
um logistic regression we had this
practice thing
we said what is the derivative of this
expression sigmoid of theta transpose
x uh where we know that sigmoid has this
beautiful slope we used the chain rule
we said okay take that input call it Z
and then we'll get the derivative of
sigmoid of Z with respect to Z and
multiply that by the derivative of Z
with respect to each Theta IJ uh and
when we did all that and plugged and
chug we ended up with this nice little
equation you can review Monday um just a
little bit of reminder of what we have
done so let's do it this Stanford we can
do something Brave derivative goals
let's start out with getting this
derivative I want the derivative of this
scoring function for one data point with
respect to a parameter here in the
output
layer first we have to decompose it we
want to use the chain rule to say okay
there's a Theta here and there's an
output here but there's this
intermediate computation which is the
computation of the probability and let's
split this up we say you know the like
log likelihood comes from this
probability and this probability comes
from this Theta and we can do
derivatives in two steps using the chain
rule we can find the derivative with
respect to Y hat multiply that by the
derivative of y hat with respect to this
particular parameter and that's
fantastic what if we wanted to then get
the D der ative with respect to one of
these inner thetas and this might be the
most important slide of today's because
this is to show you how chain rule can
make it easy to do calculations
derivatives when you go deeper and
deeper so now we have a scoring function
over here and it is impacted by a
parameter over here how can we figure
out if you were to change a parameter
here how much the scoring function would
change aka the
derivative again you could try and write
the scoring function in an equation that
has this parameter and then do the
straight but that would not work very
well instead you should use the chain
Rule and to do the chain rule you should
recognize that this leads to these
calculations these calculations leads to
this calculation this calculation leads
to your log likelihood and the chain
rule can allow you to do the derivatives
of each of those steps on their own so
the derivative with respect to this
thing will become the derivative of log
likelihood with respect to your output
probability the derivative of your
output probability with respect to your
hidden activation and the derivative of
your hidden activation with respect to
to each of these you can just chain each
of these layers together and you don't
have to do one composed derivative you
can do each derivative on its own
decomposition what a good time
so if we want to get that derivative of
log likelihood with respect to the
output parameter we'd first need this
the derivative of log likelihood with
respect to P or Y hat rather the
probability that comes out of our deep
learning
algorithm we know log likelihood is just
going to be this beri probability Mass
function logged uh and when we do the
derivative of this with respect to Y hat
it's really not that bad you know you
have this term what's this derivative
with respect to Y hat well that looks
like a constant and derivative of log of
your variable is just going to be one of
your variable something similar happens
on this right hand side we are having a
good
time you could simplify this if you
wanted to and you end up with a really
nice expression for that first term okay
not so bad that first term check done
how about the this derivative the
derivative of the output of your neural
network with respect to one of the
Hidden parameters ye don't forget the
output is defined in terms of this
logistic
regression uh you can think of this as
sigmoid of Z where Z is the inner part
that goes into the
zmo uh and just like we did before you
can say okay this derivative of y hat
with respect to that parameter uh is
going to
be this derivative over there uh
[Music]
oh oh right right right this is the
sigmoid so the sigmoid derivative is
just the sigmoid itself time 1us the
sigmoid times the derivative um of Y hat
with respect to H of the XI and you get
this but this is the same as what we had
for uh maximum likelihood estimation of
logistic regression you know this is a
very similar formula you have the output
of your logistic regression Time 1 minus
the output of your logistic regression
Times by what used to be XI but is now
hi okay not so
bad and not too scary and this really
comes from the fact that sigmoid has a
nice slope you know this is the
derivative of a
sigmoid and so it's just going to be
sigmoid Time 1 minus a sigmoid times the
derivative of uh the inside with respect
to the parameter you cared about
and we get with something not so bad at
this point we figured out the Der of log
likelihood with respect to Y hat we'
figured out the Dera of Y hat with
respect to this and we just multiply
those two things together and you would
get the derivative of live likelihood
with respect to one these output
parameters and we're almost
done we've now figured out the derivat
one of these output parameters now let's
talk about the deriv one of these input
parameters you don't need to memorize
this but I want to give you the flavor
for how chain rule is allowing us to get
bigger and bigger networks without the
math becoming
insane the way we can get this
derivative is just chain rule you know
get the derivative of this calculation
with respect to times it by the
derivative of this calculation times it
by the derivative of this calculation so
you have each of these parts on their
own this derivative we've already done
we already know the derivative of log
likelihood with respect to Y hat we
haven't done this derivative what's the
derivative of y hat with respect to one
of the H's okay you'd have to derive
this with respect to one the hes luckily
this is the derivative of a sigmoid and
a sigmoid has this nice derivative where
it's just going to be the sigmoid * 1us
sigmoid time the derivative of the
inside with respect to what you cared
about what's the derivative of this
inside with respect to HJ well there's
only one thing that's multiplied to HJ
and that's Theta J so this derivative
not so bad hey is it over almost we've
got this derivative we've got the Der of
Y hat with respect to HJ and now we just
need the derivative of HJ with respect
to one of the parameters what's HJ here
you go
we need the derivative of this with
respect to one of those
thetas now this is a little bit nice
because you're doing the derivative of
sigmoid what's the derivative of the
sigmoid it's just going to be the
sigmoid itself Time 1 minus the sigmoid
times the derivative of the inner part
with respect to what we cared about in
this case a Theta i j now there's only
one Theta i j or there's only one number
that's multiplied with Theta i j so
that's when k equals I and when k equals
i x also equals I there's only one
number that's multiplied by Theta I so
when we take the derivative of this with
respect to Theta i j we just get an x
i and we're
done and you just multiply each of these
values together your computer can
calculate this term and multiply with
this term and multiply with this term
and that will be the number that is your
derivative and that's
all wait a second you now know how to
build a neural
network and and you now know that
training is just requires you to get
these partial derivatives and chain Ru
will allow you get partial derivatives
no matter how big your network ends up
you guys could both build a neural
network and you know if you really
needed to you could sit down and you
could Implement how we could do the
training the training would use use
gradient Ascent you'd have 820
parameters and you now have equations
that you could use to calculate the
derivatives of each of those 820
parameters at any one
point and that's it you guys got it
now of course I said the positioning for
today's lecture should just be high
level I want you guys to see the details
so that you can appreciate the big
picture this isn't Magic chain rule
really is the answer to where all this
deep learning intelligence is coming
from what a powerful tool and allows us
to do intelligence with bigger and
bigger neural networks uh and so maybe
we should just have a moment of silence
to appreciate those simple facts
demystified deep learning okay
fantastic okay um so just to be clear
what would you do if we had multiple
hidden layers you would just do more
chain roll like if you want to have the
derivative with respect to these thetas
then you can have the derivative of loss
with respect to Y respect of Y with
respect to H2 the Der of H2 with respect
to H1 and D of H1 with respect to the
thetas uh you could just keep adding
chain rules uh to go deeper and deeper
in your NE
networks okay now it's time to do a
little bit of fun uh exploration you
know these neural networks there's this
great little demo site that I've got
here and it shows neural networks trying
to learn more complicated functions than
logistic regression could learn someone
asked what's the theory behind neural
networks and people would come up with
these things where you have like every
Point has an X1 X2 coordinate and then a
label either red for zero or green for
one and a neural network can learn a
circle so if all of your ones are in the
circle of this grid and all your X's are
in the outside a neural network could
learn the circle you know spatially a
neural network could learn a spiral
people got deeper and deeper into asking
what can a neural network learn and now
we feel that a neural network could
learn any function of any complexity
like there's no function that's not
complicated enough that if I got
infinite neural networks hey come on
learn sometimes they get stuck but you
know you can imagine my step size is a
little small here oh yeah I got over the
plateau keep going yes yes yes yes train
neural network
train do your chain rule okay now my
neural network is able to make good
predictions but um you know people got
deeper deeper into this and as I said we
now think that if you put enough neurons
together there is no function that you
couldn't learn if you were able to set
all the parameters
perfectly there's a couple things that I
want to add as extra ideas one of the
extra ideas is we've been talking about
binary predictions but obviously that
hand drawing digit one wanted us to make
not just binary predictions but they
want to make us predictions that were
more multinomial so like your predicted
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 we aren't going to
push you in that direction yet but if
you wanted to instead of using a sigmoid
you use a version of sigmoid called
softmax and then your loss function
would be the probability Mass function
of a multinomial not the probably Mass
function of a
beri we saw in the hand drawing digit
that not all layers were fully connected
you know at the end we had these fully
connected ones but ear on we had these
boxes and those boxes were actually
sharing weights and sharing weights is a
great idea that people called
convolution um and it turns out if you
want to do images having convolution the
first couple layers just makes for some
nice wellt trable uh neural
networks here's a crazy
thing people when they were first
starting to understand neural networks
somebody made this crazy neural network
where you would put in a face and would
predict whose face it was and they
started to put in lots of and lots of
faces into this and when they did this
the craziest thing happened they looked
at what was learned on the first layer
and they looked at what was learned in
the middle layer and they looked at what
was learned in the later layers and they
saw something
incredible when they looked at what each
neuron in the first layer was doing they
learned to do these things that look
like Edge detectors and when they looked
at what was happening in the middle
layer these neurons would be most
activated when they saw things that look
like parts of faces like one neuron
would be looking for nose one neuron
would be looking for an eye and when
they looked at later neurons they'd be
looking for like ghost faces like each
one of these neurons would be most
activated by a face that looked like
this picture you know what's insane
about that if you people look at human
brains when they look at human brains
the first part of your visual cortex is
called the V1 cortex and guess what it
looks like it looks just like that the
first part of our brain does Edge
detection if you look deeper into our
brain the next chunk of brain does
things like finding parts and then
eventually we get to higher level
Concepts like who are we seeing in this
so a neural network with the mechanism I
just told you when it was trained on
data without being told how a human
brain worked replicated some of these
Key Properties insane and at that point
people are like whoa Turing awards for
all of you
guys um obviously neural networks have
what many more than 820 neurons in fact
you know there's this Google brain
Network which does visual recognition
and this is certainly outdated but a few
years ago had a trillion uh neurons and
when you looked at those trillion
neurons they'd be you know 22 layers
deep and somebody architected each of
these layers uh painstakingly but at the
very very very very very very end is
still producing a probability of
different class
labels they trained it on a whole bunch
of things they also trained it on like
all frames from YouTube videos so got
super into cats which is just hilarious
um anyways if you looked at the
different neurons that this trillion
parameter Network learned they had
semantic meanings like you could look at
the best stimulus and You' be like okay
here is a neuron and this is really
looking for things that are diagonal but
here is a neuron it's looking for these
circular grids but later on you'd have
like there's a duck neuron there's the
flower neuron uh there's the knife
neuron and stuff like that there's this
really hard test it says I'm going to
give you an image from 22,000 categories
and you have to figure out which
category is in it was created by our own
f f Lee and these categories are pretty
specific you could get a picture of a
Stingray or you get a picture of a manta
ray and you'd have to be able to tell
the difference between those
two if you were to random guess you
would do awful at this task you know
there's 22,000 classes before neural
networks people spent a lot of time
trying to get really good at this and
they got to about 1.5% accuracy and
people got papers off of 1.5% accuracy
and at some point people started using
neural networks for this and they
started to get closer to like 44%
accuracy you know humans can get close
to 93% accuracy and the most uh up up
toate neural networks can outperform
humans on this task and we kind of know
this um how many parameters is too many
it turns out if you have enough data and
you have enough computer power the scary
thing is it doesn't seem like there is a
limit here we in this really weird world
where if you throw more compute power
that can do more gradient descent and
you have more parameters you have more
data there doesn't seem to be a ceiling
the models just seem to get smarter and
smarter and that's why there's such a
weird arms race going on between like
Google and gpt3 and all these folks to
make the best neural network um I'm
going to talk about this more on Friday
um and yeah I'll bring this up too I do
want to lightly note that not
everything's classification and I would
like to leave on this note of this
little critter we had training from the
beginning of class do you guys want to
go check in on our Critter ah there's
our
Critter here's our Critter and this
Critter is now gotten pretty smart like
the critor has now figured out okay I
want to go and I want to re eat all the
red dots without eating all the green
dots how does this Critter
work you can look at this Critter's
neural network what's its inputs it has
all these lines and it knows a distance
and a color of what it sees based on
those inputs it then has a whole neural
network but then it has a very final
output and that very final output
doesn't look like it's predicting or one
or zero does
it it's predicting an action to take one
of the actions is is move left one of
the actions is move right one of the
actions is move really far left and one
of the actions move really far right and
one of the actions is move forward uh
and so at the very end it's just
predicting which of these actions it
should
take its loss function you know the
thing that was optimizing was based off
of looking at its experience and saying
hm was I getting good food to eat or
not what a time to be alive you know
this is just the start we can talk a
little bit more about how far this has
gone but you guys have understood that
full picture like this simple idea of
putting logistic regressions on top of
each other that's what's
behind algorithms that can make
decisions that's what's Behind These
algorithms that can draw pictures that's
what's behind you know the self-driving
cars it all comes to logistic agressions
put together trains my chain rule what a
crazy world we live in have a fantastic
day come back on Friday we'll talk about
ethics and fairness uh before our very
final week of school have a great day CS
109 oh if you ask a question come get a
mandarin
front